le ministre des finances georges c'est
de là bas je dépose aujourd'hui le
deuxième budget de notre gouvernement
aucun virage il ya aucune ambition le
gouvernement a tenu ses engagements
et ça donne un résultat qui va être très
mauvais service très mauvais goût la
croissance économique du québec le
budget équilibré pour nous c'est
essentiel c'est important on est
aujourd'hui difficile d eau
mais à quel prix grands dieux ensemble
on développe notre économie alors on ne
pourra pas reprocher au gouvernement
couillard de ne pas avoir tenu promesse
et le retour à l'équilibré budgétaire au
québec
mais quelles en seront les conséquences
tasha est à toronto daniel et à ottawa
et michel et à québec michel justement
vous avez assisté au dévoilement de ce
budget donc retour à l'équilibré
budgétaire après six ans de déficit mais
on l'entendrait plusieurs se posent la
question à quel prix un prix très lourd
a indéniablement à écouter des dépenses
qui vont être en augmentation de 1,2
pour ça c'est totalement aux 0,7 pour
cent qui était prévu l'an dernier cas la
coupure et elle y a qu'à l'augmentation
réelle qui a été simplement de 2,1 pour
ça donc c'est moins que l'an dernier que
beaucoup de gens ont trouvé très
difficile déjà alors ça va être très dur
etc je pense que quand on regarde les
projections un peu plus long terme c'est
son espèce d'autorité à demeure qui
s'installe parce que même quand on va
voir vraiment
retrouvez des surplus budgétaires par
exemple en 2016-17 on va des
augmentations de dépenses simplement de
l'ordre de 2,2 pour ça ce qui est très
très en deçà de ce à quoi on avait été
habituée au cours des dernières années
alors c'est presque un changement de
modèle complet dans lequel on à daniels
un mal nécessaire ou est ce que le
gouvernement aurait pu prendre un peu
plus de temps pour y arriver
un mal nécessaire quand vous avez une
dette 290 milliards de dollars qui
représente 50% de votre pib quand vous
payer entre 10 et 12 milliards de
dollars juste pour les intérêts quand
les grandes sociétés de notation vous
ont à l'oeil sans arrêt et menacent de
réduire votre club vous n'avez pas
beaucoup le choix est ce que la proche
de monsieur couillard et de son
gouvernement était la bonne
est-ce qu'il a effectué les compressions
beaux endroits ont pu en débattre à
l'infini sur mende et endosse a fait
très mal
ça touche directement à la population
même si le gouvernement avait dit non et
ce qu'ils avaient pu espionner et
davantage toute cette opération
probablement le problème c'est que dans
ce genre d'opérations extrêmement à
douloureuse difficile
plus vous tardez à la faire plus vous
étirer la sauce puis ça devient
compliqué plus les gens se rebelle
contre vous vaut mieux et c'est la
théorie de bien des gens et y aller
rapidement
tasha je voyais à prouver ce qu'elle
disait je suis d'accord avec daniel je
pense que dans le cas ici mais ce client
n'avait pas beaucoup de choix et ceux
qui lui reprochent que c'est un budget
de 2010 est oui le 2015 écoute il faut
s'il veut ramener la province à l'ordre
financièrement le faire avant la
prochaine élection qui va être en 2018
il sait bien que c'est quand même
monsieur ron paul a fait aussi que c'est
le moment avant cette élection là de
rembourser les gens qui ont souffert
sous l'austérité c'est à dire les
contribuables qui vont voir certainement
des impacts sur les services et il n'y a
pas de question mais ça me met en
question justement le modèle comme
michel a dit le modèle québécois qui
l'a entraînée dans la situation on se
retrouve et peut-être s'étend d'un
différents modèles
ça tombe aussi bien parce que on voit le
dollar est bas le prix de l'essence est
bas l'économie québécoise roule assez
bien alors je pense que la combinaison
avec l'austérité
ils ont de fortes chances à regret qu'il
y brille l'économie et le budget en même
temps michel on pourra plus faire les
choses comme on les faisait un vol va
falloir changer notre façon de faire est
de toute évidence non mais il va avoir
des éclopés dans l'opération parce que
c'est bien vous dire que les gens les
contribuables vont être soulagés à
partir de 2017 mais d'abord il ya 40%
des gens qui ne paient pas d'impôts qui
ne paient pas de taxes antennes ont plu
et qui souffre des coupures qui ont été
opéré l'an dernier et qui vont l'être de
façon encore plus douloureuse cette
année à la spa vrai qu'il n'y aura pas
des laissés pour compte dans cette
opération là tout le monde espère que la
croissance va finir par être au rendez
vous parce que ce qu'on annonce là en
tout cas les chiffres qui sont contenues
dans le budget nous laisse extrêmement
loin de l'engagement de 250 mille
emplois pendant le mandat au cours du
au cours des prochaines années ou de
sorte qu'il y ait pas évident que les
revenus que de la croissance économique
vont être au rendez-vous alors il va
falloir attendre en bout de ligne pour
voir si le comment dire le soulagement
est réelle et pour qui oui parlons de 8h
à j'allais dire le but de l'exercice est
qu'il n'ya pas 40% qui ne paie pas
d'impôts que ces gens-là augmente le
revenu est justement le gouverneur
reconnaissant que si vous avez une
augmentation vous donner un crédit pour
ça pour encourager qu'il y assez des
augmentations que les gens reçoivent
plus d'argent est effectivement qu'ils
vont payer des taxes fin de la journée
mais daniel en santé par exemple ça va
faire très mal je sais pas juste le
québec il ya d'autres provinces ou sinon
d'ici c'est le québec peut se consoler
et il ya un problème de santé il est
majeur au québec il est majeur partout
romane où l'on sait premier ce
saskatchewan celui à qui l'on est
chrétien demande de faire une étude sur
la santé disait ces derniers jours le
système de santé canadien est sur le
point d'exploser je vous parle pas
d'années je vous parle de moi
ainsi peut-être plus pessimistes comme
diagnostic sauf que ça vient de
quelqu'un qui sait de quoi il parle il
ya un problème majeur dans le système de
santé canadien
beaucoup de gens se console en se disant
c'est d'abord et on l'entend beaucoup au
québec un problème d'organisation du
travail beaucoup plus que de financement
sauf qu'il ya aussi un problème de
financement et au canada la loi sur la
santé
le garant de la loi sur la santé si le
gouvernement fédéral donc à yves à venir
un jour et monsieur romano l'évoqué ou
du vendômois fédéral va devoir même si
monsieur harper n'aime pas ça ne veut
rien savoir de rencontrer le premier
ministre va devoir s'asseoir avec eux et
se dire si on veut maintenir l'intégrité
de cette loi canadienne sur la santé
il va peut-être falloir que tous
ensemble nous renvoie santé qu'on
repense aux transferts que le fédéral
fait aux provinces le domaine de la
santé qui je pense aux gelées en ce
moment mais il ya une autre il ya une
autre possibilité à terme c'est que face
à l'impossibilité de financer le système
à son niveau actuel les gens se tournent
de plus en plus vers le privé parce que
l'homme monsieur coiteux nous dit on va
baisser les coûts de système par les
réformes de structure à écouter les
réformes de structure on va voir combien
avons généré
de l'économie il est fort possible qu'il
génère plutôt des dépenses et à partir
du moment où vous passez un projet de
loi pour faire en sorte que les médecins
soignent davantage de patients serait
bien surprenant que ça coûte moins cher
c'est quelque chose ça va coûter plus
cher mais ça va au débat de la société
que débat société qu'on veut avoir
justement est-ce qu'on peut rouler avec
un système à une vitesse et est
simplement par l'état à infinite et non
la majorité des pays dans le monde ont
des systèmes à double vitesse où ces
permis d'avoir à des soins privés s'est
permis d'avoir deux et en même chose
pour l'éducation les étudiants doivent
se poser la question
vu que on paye presque le double pour
l'université dans le reste du canada
est ce que c est ce qu'on peut continuer
à voir on a vécu ça il ya deux ans de ce
débat mais ce qu'on peut continuer à
avoir des tarifs aussi bas pour une
université sera pas sans passer par la
ministre blais avec les manifestations
étudiantes qui commence en plus il a
déjà dit on peut pas prendre l'argent
des étudiants primaire et secondaire
pour les donner aux universitaires je
pense qu'il a envoyé le message assez
clair et je pense que la population
québécoise aussi est moins intéressé en
2015 qu'en 2012 et 2013 cette question
au gouvernement précédent souligne eh
oui le gouvernement prétend que ça
n'affectera pas les services alors c'est
très bien dire le modèle a éclaté çà
mais le gouvernement lui ni oreiller
clair aussi bien en santé qualification
quel et nice des services ne pourront
pas être maintenues à leur niveau actuel
il ya déjà écouté et je t'ai la semaine
dernière l'invité de l'alliance des
professeurs de montréal qui avait son
congrès jamais rencontré de gens aussi
des prix mais aussi désabusés par le
système pas à cause des négociations
juste par sucre sont pas capables de
faire le travail comme ils veulent le
faire ils sont capables d'aider les
élèves qui ont besoin d'avoir de l'aide
tout le système a été l'objet de moult
réformes depuis quelques années
tout est très confus on a changé le
ministre de l'éducation comme on change
de mauvais joueur de hockey il ya non
mais c'est peut-être l'erreur du
gouvernements clients aujourd'hui de ne
pas penser s'imaginer que le système de
ce d'éducation au besoin d'être renforcé
et pendant ce temps tâche à l'alberta
déposer également son budget aujourd'hui
on le voyait là déficit de 5 milliards
une taxe de santé qui revient tout à
coup donc c'est vraiment le contraste là
quand même
c'est absolument contraste des impôts
qui vont augmenter la fin de
l'imposition unique qui était le seul au
canada à cette promesse à la voie celle
inverse du québec effectivement il est
en même temps ils ont un déficit alors
mais on s'attendait à ça écoute les
albertains ont bien se plaindre mais la
réalité c'est que leurs gouvernants
dépenser beaucoup beaucoup pendant les
années grâce à plus de ses moyens oui a
été le paie la note
cette fois ci c'est très dur mais
maintenant il va aussi donner -
interrogation ce qui est ce qui a fait
que le québec aussi parce que
l'albertain maintenant puis le cousin
riche de l'ouest mais ce qui est
intéressant de surveiller ce que
l'alberta n'étant plus le cousin est
riche de l'ouest tranquillement la force
économique du canada va se déplacer vers
le chante et c'est l'ontario le québec
aussi beaucoup qui vont profiter on l'a
déjà dit du prix du pétrole à la baisse
du dollar américain à 85 déjà des
exportations au québec commencent à
remonter
donc il va peut-être avoir un changement
qui va se faire combien de temps va
durer la crise pétrolière ses prix à la
baisse
c'est mon fils adoré le moindrement
longtemps à vous allez voir ce transfert
de la vigueur économique du canada vers
l'ouest au centre du pays
mais dans l'immédiat je pense qu'il ya
pas beaucoup de gens au québec en tout
cas qui vont pleurer sur le sort des
albertains
écoutez il ya toujours pas de taxe de
vente là bas le taux d'impôt sur la tête
de taxes d'impôts sur le revenu dis-je
demeure nettement en deçà de ce qu'il
est ici qu'on détruise loin d'impôts
qu'on a introduit un peu de
progressivité dans le système ça devrait
faire plaisir à beaucoup de gens non
honnêtement je vois pas tellement que
les albertains pour le moment en tout
cas
soit beaucoup peuple un bon jour est
quand même qu'on dise un mot en
terminant sur le débat à ottawa sur la
prolongation de la mission en irak et
maintenant qui va avoir lui aussi en
syrie mon seul l'adoption de la motion
c'est juste une formalité puisque les
conservateurs sont majoritaires mais
tâche a quand même ça ça clarifie les
choses un petit peu sur l'échiquier
politique d'un côté des conservateurs
qui sont pour de l'autre les partis
d'opposition mais de l'autre le parti
d'opposition le pdc plus car c'est les
libéraux qui se trouve un peu dans le
camp dit en anglais un machine rôles
centre mou parce que monsieur monsieur
trudeau dit cui troupe des 69 entraîneur
oui les avions non on peut pas avoir le
beurre et l'argent du beurre comme on
dit ah et je pense que c'est les deux
gagnants dans cette histoire vraiment si
monsieur mulcair et monsieur un peu
qu'ils ont les positions opposées et
kibo qui leur électorat appuie ces deux
positions opposées
michel oui ben monsieur trudeau se
retrouve encore d'un vélo 1 c je n'ai
pas mal d'entre vous jeudi poussé sa
position naturelle mais je pense que la
majeure partie de la population fera pas
beaucoup les distinctions qui sont
introduites entre l'irak la syrie
d'un point de vue militaire j'imagine ça
justifie ce l'ennemi se déplacent soient
liés où il est et je ne sais pas le jeu
de bachar al assad bien entendu ça fait
le jeu de la chasse mais vu d'ici je
pense que la plupart déjà feront front
poste s'est tenue en cela veut dire
écoutez il faut détruire l'état
islamique et on va aller chercher là où
il est alors je pense que c'est un bon
calcul électoral à tout le moins de la
part de ce qu'on peut faire une
différence vraiment daniel on a juste
six avions quand même
écoutez bien faire une chance et
peut-être pas si c'est peut-être plus
symbolique qu'autre chose sauf que bon
le travail que fera au canada là bas il
est vrai parfois il ya déjà eu plusieurs
sorties de ces avions là sauf que sauf
que il y avait un sondage en fin
l'après-midi écosse qui démontrait que
l'appui à
à la mission avec diminué au canada est
passé de 60 à quelque 52 53 % ça reste
encore assez élevé et même s'ils
savaient et si ça devait tomber à 40 %
un peu ne s'entraînera pas avec 40%
canada vous gagnez des élections et vous
êtes majoritaires c'est ce qui compte
pour lui en ce moment donc cette mission
a toutes les chances de se retrouver au
coeur de la prochaine campagne
électorale
c'est tout le temps qu'on a
malheureusement merci beaucoup à vous
trois chaînes et dimanche à 11 heures
aux coulisses du pouvoir emmanuelle
latraverse reçoit justement le ministre
fédéral de la défense nationale jason
kenny